cette année cette année à nouveau mode
m'a confié le rôle de chauffeur de salle
alors
j'ai quelques doutes sur l'utilité d'un
chauffeur de salle parce que je sens que
l'enthousiasme est bien là et qu'il est
perceptible et qu'il remplit très
largement cette salle et si
l'enthousiasme est là c'est parce que
Guidel c'est ce rendez-vous unique pour
nous les démocrates qui à la fois source
et vecteur d'énergie tant pour nos
engagements individuels que pour
l'engagement collectif que nous portons
tous ensemble à travers le Mouvement
Démocrate
et tout particulièrement après l'année
2023 que l'on a traversé la prise de
hauteur que ces trois jours ont permis
était nécessaire et attendu par tout le
monde
car face à l'exercice l'exacerbation des
clivages et la radicalisation du débat
public que l'on a connu notamment tout
au long du printemps
la voie que nous portons et plus que
jamais nécessaire juste et essentiel et
d'ailleurs on en a fait la vérification
avec les Jeunes Démocrates j'espère
président que vous avez remarqué cette
année que les jeunes sont nombreux à
Guidel ils sont
les jeunes les jeunes sont nombreux en
nombre et ils sont nombreux en
proportion participants il faudrait
vérifier avec mes prédécesseurs mais je
pense qu'on n'est pas loin d'un record
et c'est et c'est assez logique
finalement parce que c'est durant cette
année 2023 logique et paradoxal parce
que c'est durant cette année 2023 de
trouble de turbulences d'agitation du
débat public que les Jeunes Démocrates
ont fait un nombre de nouvelles recrues
record également
alors évidemment vous me permettrez de
souligner que c'est dû à la très grande
qualité du travail de votre mouvement de
jeunesse mais
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
mais surtout me permettrait d'y voir là
un marqueur de plus de la justesse de
notre approche du débat public de la
pertinence du message que nous délivrons
et de l'écho qu'il suscite auprès de nos
concitoyens
alors chers amis il ne nous reste plus
qu'à maintenir le cap maintenir le cap
pour le Mouvement Démocrate et maintenir
le cap pour les jeunes démocrates en
premier lieu ça a été dit et redit je
vais pas revenir là-dessus nous avons un
centenaire assez livré l'année prochaine
et nous sommes attendus et nous avons
rendez-vous avec l'Europe l'année
prochaine et c'est donc sans transition
que j'appelle notre député européenne
Marie-Pierre vedren à me succéder à ce
pupitre merci à tous
[Applaudissements]